so what I just said is that we've got no
one to make me three arriving either
today or Wednesday
I don't think so the old maker three is
one of the best 3d printers you can get
oh but it's important to clarify it we
didn't get this from Ultimaker our
friends at mater hacker actually gave
this to us if you're printing something
that has like an overhang you need
something to support that because it's
building it up from the base and the
cool thing about this printer is the
support stuff that it prints is
water-soluble so you don't have to sit
there and clip it off and stand off a
little bumps on your model this way you
can just take it and put it in water and
then take it out of water and you're
done exactly because it can print two
different filaments at the same time so
it prints the regular plastic and then
it prints the water-soluble plastic with
a separate printhead thanks mater
hackers great morning runs every single
day for the last five years two and a
half miles so what's interesting about
this is it has really thick filaments so
this is I think the water-soluble stuff
yeah I'm incredibly excited to try this
ultimate car outperform two was a
wonderful experience as well the form 2
uses a liquid based like laser system
and this is a little more traditional
PVA plastic and PLA plastic yeah it's a
little bit of apples and oranges they
both kind of have their strengths and
weaknesses
I'd say the strength of the ultime Kerr
is definitely size you can build things
and print things that are much larger
and less expensive far more conveniently
a lot more conveniently
they're back
whenever someone or all of us leaves our
garbage out over a weekend fly spot we
hit the camera and now it's fly huntin
season they're still corpses on my desk
right here here's one fly - oh there's
one on the pen dude why are there so
many yeah landing on my face I'm gonna
go these flies are grade one quick stir
guys what's in the box let's make your
three remove the packaging install the
printer copy that all right so gently
place the printer on its side insert the
spool holder to the back panel and push
it until it snaps in place
it's the build plate where the plastic
lives so all the prints are created off
this open the front build plate clamps
to insert the glass plate make sure the
glass plate slides into the rear clamps
and close clam yeah hit it it's like
every summer someone takes him like real
stinky food and they just like they
leave it in the bin over the weekend and
Andrea flies to deal with it sucks
I'd be pretty funny seriously you're
totally possible
come on two little rods and it's I think
it's a really easy first test and also
relevant
got it it's all about that flick doing
really well
the Nerf method is working flawlessly I
thought we can kill them all but dude
there's so many more okay the next step
is to load the printer with materials
place the new spool on the spool holder
got my school I insert it into this tiny
little slot in the back and it just
wound it up and shot it through this
tube here and since the hard material
once the material hits the head it's
gonna start squirting out liquid
material
oh it's feeding yeah it's not doing the
turbo feed that the last one the last
one it was like oh that noise
[Music]
this is a plastic filament that's been
extruded at point four millimeters not a
confirmed kill hold them there be very
still
yeah for honestly just think flytraps
[Music]
how big is that wire exactly two
millimeters all right cool so fashioned
a handle probably twisted did twisting
it or something I don't know just make
it sturdy and then up I'll just whip
something up here cool
so this is roughly 8 by 9 hoping it
doesn't pan over this thicker if it does
let her yeah cool figured it out got the
scaling right got everything right
well I guess I just turned it on plugged
everything in hopefully it works dude
yes your print turned out nice due to
the high detail kind of like very thin
kind of structure oh my god the landing
on it did you see that maybe scratch him
to ramp it the computer made some
polygons and then hit print there's one
on your hit no Mike almost almost
oh I see one
you don't want it so hard that you like
the tanks c'mon hurry
but the explosion yes and blew it up on
the fly yeah you go to sit fly like goes
perfectly through one of the holes is
like good so I guess this is a little
brittle for a fly swatter but it's
really stylish it's really stylish
flyswatter I still think if you make it
like super thin like maybe like two or
three layers thick and be able to be
flexible enough to continue being uses
the next oh dude it's sorry or shattered
sorry I'm fly yeah I've killed so many
flies so many flies
close it around
[Music]
this printer works much differently this
uses a pool of plastic to make layers it
will feed liquid into this tray and
there's gonna be a little laser
underneath it that shoots lasers into
the liquid hardening it piece by piece
this allows it to create 3d prints with
laser accuracy